what's the most painful thing you've
been told I'm gonna kill yourself
I'll shadows never your friends movie
little ta why you don't person do you
remember how it made you feel it made me
feel sad it made me feel quite sad and
made me think
yeah very sad do you remember who said
it one of my best friends and how'd it
make you feel are you still friends with
that you are so how are you able to like
move past it and stay friends with them
I feel it if toilets at some shake it up
and so I just shook it up well the first
time I ever met my dad I was about 13
years old and I was really excited I had
my curly hair all out and he told me
that the next time he saw me he would
want me to straighten my hair made me
feel really self-conscious and really
uncomfortable in my own skin that's all
yeah as I grew older I just came into my
own style and you know I'm just with
Russia's embrace the things that make me
different and and yes so now I love my
curly hair for me I have never really
been taught told like anything as
painful as like the thoughts that go on
in my own head yeah I just
who knows it was never really like
anything suicidal or anything I know
some people have but a lot of time I
just never really felt good enough or
like I could I was good enough I sort of
just always compared myself to people
better like better than me and I always
thought I wasn't worthy enough and just
yeah it was constant like negative
thoughts well the most beautiful thing
somebody has said to me is not just like
for once but they said me so many times
like different Punjabi people like a
proper job
so they said me that I'm not look I
don't look like a Punjabi and I'm very
ugly to head even have a girlfriend so
that's the more thoughtful like more
troublesome thing that I will like still
it's in my heart like it's in my mind
these things it's taken to mind that ok
I'm ugly I can't even have a girlfriend
and I'm 28 years old and I don't him
don't have a girlfriend I just think
that I'm ugly that's why I always try to
like change their mind but I'm really
unsuccessful I common successful than
that till now but yeah sometimes yeah
I'm usually the one that shaves painful
news so I'm a pediatric oncologist so I
works with children with cancer so I
have to relay that diagnosis to the
parents
and the most pose painful of their whole
journey he is sometimes when we can't
cure the kids anymore to tell the
parents that there is nothing more to do
so
yeah that's quite extreme and I have one
daughter she's 8 years old she's a
specialist my special daughter she's
autistic and most of the people from our
family is say they used to see me might
you did something really bad
that's why God blessed you with such
special daughter and that's really
terrible for me one set of life so
painting for me it's really painful for
me like once people say oh you did worse
in your past or in your youth like God
given you such child thankful to God
like he given me such a baby I'm used to
take care of her like anything I love
her and I always say like thank God
you've given me such a baby my time
special that she'd given me a special
child that it was our house that burnt
down
we were on our way home and there was an
ambulance that took a rough Street and
they were trying to figure out whose
house it was
and it was house
probably when my husband told us Tommy
that it was leaving me because he didn't
want to be a part of a family anymore
and it hated me for years um well we had
we have three children so he said it to
them as well so it was pretty good
that's pretty heartbreaking yeah
and we can talk him out of it so yeah
when people say you can come if you want
because it makes you feel like they
don't really want you there it's just
nice to know that you know it's like
it'd be better if they like kind of made
you feel a bit more welcoming stuff into
saying can come if he likes it makes you
feel like you're not really wanted and
it can make you put yourself down I
think the most hurtful thing someone
said to me is you're fired
and I guess that's yeah that's
reasonably lucky that that is the most
type of thing that comes to mind when I
when I racked my brains and not just Gia
fired but we're not going to tell you
why so I think there's that sense of
injustice that type of hurt is really
hard to
to get past especially when there's no
possibility of closure
I'm sure there are other hurts and
things that have said to me in my life
but that that one comes immediately to
mind just because I felt it sort of
roiling through me so long
someone's told me that I'm a bad person
that's the most hurtful because it's so
simple
it isn't specific about any
characteristic of me or any attribute
that I have just as a person I'm bad and
that simplicity stuck out to me I was in
a chemistry high school class and then
my teacher called me four eyes like I
was like I wear glasses I need to see it
like I can't frickin see yeah I can I
was like piss me off a lot back then
when I was a kid but now I love my
glasses I have two peers I'm gonna get a
no two again
now I'm like whatever I might be wear my
glasses I didn't have to say so I said
so a most painful thing somebody ever
told me was I was pathetic and like I
did they didn't really mean it as bad as
I did but it definitely like hit home
you know like it was just something I've
never been told I didn't know how much
it would hurt and I was kind of like wow
that was you know that's intense to see
you know early last year I came home one
day and found a pamphlet on the kitchen
bench that just said dealing with
prostate cancer and that was how I found
out the right dad
I'd cancer and I picked it up and I was
like dad what is this
and he came into the room so me holding
it and was like sit down and yeah that's
it
well he just had radiation so we are
waiting
probably after my mom died they said
that I was being attention-seeking but
I'm damaged someone said to me that I
was completely useless and everything
probably you're annoying like it really
hits the heart so I'm telling you you're
in no way can't really fix how you are
when my brother calls me train tracks
because of my braces well I just laugh
along with you the kid at school this
year call me foul how did you deal with
it my friend texted him and went to go
slap him at school recently I thought I
was dressed quite nicely walked up to a
fairly standard pub and was denied entry
because I wasn't up to stand I was at
school and I was with some friends and I
got a phone call telling me that a
friend had passed away and that
I didn't realize that he was feeling
this way
he seems normal and was supposed to like
hang out like like the next few days he
wasn't showing signs of like
I'd say the most cutting thing that
someone said to me it was when I came
home from a really nice day and my mom
said my best friend had just died
really hot I was grieving for a solid
month or two loss your mom like three
years ago
well you cannot explain it it's just
like you feel empty that my pop died
like yeah like came home from like a
party and I was in a really good mood
and my family was just sitting and like
they were overly Samba and I was like
this copy good
growing up I sit called fagner my last
name is Wagner clever
I don't know it uh it kind of just stuck
everybody called me fagner that's what I
was known as for a while just kind of
belittled who I was I felt like I just
kind of made it even more more of a
difficult thing to try to come out as
gay my dad we're in a fight and kind of
painful other multiple you want to heal
and he told me I couldn't be me which is
painful because like I can't be myself
around anyone and if I can't be myself
around my family it's like out of their
at me that's why he asked me but hit
myself in the face asking me why my
eyebrows why so I used to stutter
heavily until I was about 14 years old
could barely speak and someone made fun
of me about that so what I try to say
something and I couldn't articulate
myself and they were pointed out like
you know imitate me or make fun of me
for starting that was terrible there's
no way to defend yourself against that
you have that disability and someone
points that out it's a reality and it's
just hard to get away from but one thing
I will never do is try to fill in a
sentence for someone that's stuttering I
used to do it I know what it feels like
it's terrible so I guess I learned
something from it
when my head of sick form told me I'd
never get into university let's say I
just took a whole day of school to go
home and basically cry about it yeah I
started September in the end so what's
your name my name is Tony and where you
from I live in the Gold Coast in
Australia and what's the most painful
things you've been told you know I don't
I can't really think of anything this
really really hurt me which in a way is
a good thing I'm sure there have been
but you know you just deal with that you
you move on and it stings a bit at the
time but you know looking back I can't
say there's one thing that really really
did hurt me so I'm happy
hi everyone as you could tell I'm in
Australia for the first time in a really
long time I was pretty nervous to go out
and film an episode just because
obviously I don't know the area but
everyone has been so friendly so I just
want to thank Sydney and the people here
you guys truly know how to show kindness
to a stranger
I believe my senior your YouTube video I
seen you YouTube video interviewing
people yeah yeah that's me what's your
name my name is Steve nice to meet you
here's here's one of the kind people in
Sydney what was your name again man and
you said you watch my videos yeah I did
I tend to watch some YouTube videos of
yours uh-huh
like I'm when I'm training have you ever
been to California ah no I want to go
yeah you should check it out that's
where I'm from the next time I come to
Cali I'll look for you yeah I'll look at
the feelings yeah yeah for sure check
out San Diego that's my City cool well
did you
yeah have a good one all right see you
later yeah that's pretty much it but
before you go please leave a suggestion
for a city I should film at next and say
hi to me on Instagram thank you guys for
watching and I'll see you next week
[Music]